what we do on a regular basis because we
love you
the audience and we're committed to this
show we check cameo cameo for those of
you who don't know
is this [ __ ] crazy thing that's
developed on the internet where
celebrities
sell themselves to make birthday
messages and anniversary messages for
you
do you know it has gotten bigger and
bigger since the pandemic
because real stars started going
on cameo you could buy a message from
mandy moore
on the same website you can get ass
napkin ed and it's like what a
juxtaposition
it's crazy he charges like 19 bucks
oh wow and yeah well okay it's a
realistic price
but i got a figure so realistic i'm
shocked at a task napkin head doing it
and it's weird when you go on cameo they
even have to categorize
what the message is because you can't
tell like is this a birthday message
what
yeah this was the category was pep talk
because you know you want to go out and
do something great after years
oh my goodness hello apex
how you say i hope you're doing okay
i know that biom it's a lot of work
this is matt kovacs i mean it's
by me it's from that for
after fifth and um
we get a party sometime along with dan
bills um this is not worth
19 howard he hasn't said a complete word
yet yeah but isn't that what you want
from mass napkin end i mean
oh by the way you know who else is on
cameo and i'll give him a plug cause you
know i love the guy will defarter
oh he is
here we go happy birthday to
happy birthday to you jesus
happy birthday dear
[Music]
happy birthday to
i think there's construction going on
hope you enjoy that man
farts are just funny and if especially
his because it always sounds like he's
on the verge of [ __ ] his pants
you know what i mean it's always wet at
the end it's always like and
that could happen too can go ahead
quickly
thank you yeah man i just want to say
man cammy always been good to me
can you hear me on cameo i've been on i
was on camera for about a year
i made eighteen thousand wow
can you hear me can you hear me cameo
can you hear me yes can you hear me
right now
stop get out of here get off my phone
i mean my god can you hear me there's an
amazing ability with me i actually tuned
out of my own show i was listening to
another show in my head
while he was talking
you